we are hearing the very chilling new
details about the abduction of Jamie
Claus and the murder of her parents back
in October a newly released court
complaint shows that 21 year-old Jake
Thomas Patterson admitted to the crimes
right away
Wisconsin judge charged him yesterday
with two counts of first-degree homicide
one count of kidnapping and one count of
armed burglary
Jamie yuccas is at the Barron County
Jail Jamie with more on this story it
was very tough to read those documents
yesterday we all said the same thing
Gale good morning Jake Patterson
allegedly told investigators he drove to
the kloss home twice before the
abduction to try and duck and abduct
Jamie at that point in time but when he
saw people inside he left he got scared
off now on his third attempt the night
of the actual kidnapping he allegedly
turned off his headlights and shot his
way inside sir anything at all about the
shotgun used Jake Patterson's father and
brother held hands as they left Monday's
hearing in Barron County Wisconsin
moments earlier Patterson briefly
appeared in court via videoconference to
face the charges against him yet enough
time to discuss the waiver of time
limits with your attorneys according to
a criminal complaint Patterson did not
know Jamie Claus prior to her abduction
but he watched the 13 year-old get on a
school bus and had made the decision at
that point that he was going to take her
according to the complaint
Jamie was woken up by her barking dog
early in the morning of October 15th
she then noticed someone driving up
their driveway and went to wake up her
parents Patterson wearing a face mask in
gloves
allegedly shot and killed Jamie's father
James with a 12-gauge shotgun through
the front door and then forced his way
into the home Jamie's mother Denise
called 911 and barricaded themselves in
a bathroom Patterson broke in told her
to hang up and ordered her to put tape
over Jamie's mouth he then allegedly
shot Denise in the head killing her
investigators say Patterson told them he
bound Jaime's ankles and hands with tape
put her in the trunk of his car and
drove her to his home in Gordon
Wisconsin Richard Jones and Charley
Glenn represe
Patterson is there any chance that there
could be an insanity plea we have to
explore all the options and not guilty
by mental disease or defect is always an
option to look at we will explore all of
those we don't know at this point Jamie
told investigators Patterson hit her
under his bed when guests came over
using laundry bins and weights to keep
her from moving
last Thursday Patterson allegedly
ordered Jamie to hide under the bed
while he went out she instead escaped
she put on Patterson's shoes they were
on the wrong feet but she was able then
she walked out the front door she just
sort of fell into me and said I'm Jamie
and I said I know Gayle King spoke to
Jeanne Nutter who brought Jamie to a
nearby house to call 911 flagged her
down what are you thinking about when
you think about how brave she yes I'm
just I don't you know what 13 year old
has it in them to endure what she has
and then find the courage and just to
get out I'm just so proud of her
prosecutors say there are additional
details that are not included at this
point in this criminal complaint
Patterson now faces life in prison he's
being held in this jail on five million
dollars bail his next court appearance
is in February where he is expected to
enter a plea viana Jamie thank you and
Gayle we knew that these details were
going to be hard to hear and gruesome
and the only thing that gives you some
hope is the fact that Jamie's with loved
ones the one you sat with yesterday yeah
if you can never think that you know
love will pull you through that is
exactly what we all believe will happen
here I mean the more you hear about the
details we already thought that she was
brave but the more that you hear and how
what she really went through it really
shows you it's amazing that she had the
presence of mind because he had been he
in the complaint he says that he had he
had hit her a couple of times hoping to
scare her into submission so somehow she
figured out a way that I have to take a
shot and I have to get out of here she
says a lot of it's good to know she's
got a good community there to help her
throne you know yeah addition to her
family you're right everybody in the
town has close ranks around Jamie she's
well protected at this time